first of two talks on the CCA security
in the kiki realm and then after the
those two tops there'll be sort of vh
amir in the quran so now we've entered
the quantum part of the workshop that
will last just today alright so go ahead
Catherine thanks we thank you and hi to
everyone and welcome to my talk
so yesterday we've already seen corner
letters constructions beyond botanists
currently standardizing but today I want
to drag you back to the in this
competition because there's been ongoing
research when it comes to encryption
schemes and I want to tell you a bit
about what the current state of the art
is sorry so in this competition we are
aiming for the quantum secure public
encryption schemes and the level of
security we would be aiming for is
active security which means the security
against chosen ciphertext the text and
what's way easier to construct a
specific impressive security which means
one-wayness are indistinguishable 'ti
under chosen plaintext attacks but lucky
we already know that the foot is a key
Okamoto transformation and its variants
achieves exactly the goal of turning
active passive security interactive
security and our current nist proposals
use a variant of the arrow
transformation
to achieve CCA security the original
profile ever was given in the random
Oracle model and in this talk I sketch
how we have to adapt the proof if we
want to consider adversaries that come
with quantum capabilities
okay so I already want to give a pointer
to the next talk which covers a very
nice result that was currently accepted
to Europe crypt and in order to enable
you to put this result into context I
gave a survey that covers what is
currently known so first I have a bit
about how the quantum random Oracle
model is defined and one of the most
important tools we are currently using
for if Oh like transformations which is
one way to hiding and afterwards I
gather what all if oleg transformations
have in common and the results we know
have in common and where they differ
ok so first the quick reminder on
security reductions and the quantum
random Oracle model so our in the Oracle
model method methodology is a proof
Urist ik in which we replace a hash
function with a perfectly random
function H which we call the random
Oracle and a common prosperity in our if
Olek proof is to argue the randomness to
the adversary of a particular random
Oracle value and our argument goes as
follows we argue that if a could
distinguish this Oracle value from
random it would have had to query the or
occur on this pre image first
hence the reduction as the pre image in
this pre image might solve an underlying
problem like the one-wayness of the
encryption scheme but what happens if a
is quantum
so the scenario we are considering is a
scenario in which we have a quantum
advisory but this advisory is still
interacting with a non quantum network
so we are not assuming and a quantum
internet and this implies that online
primitives like to Krypton and signing
statistical but offline primitives like
hash functions are computable in
superposition so what's new the hash
function might be evaluated in some
superposition which I will denote like
this in just in case someone forgot what
a superposition is I give a quick
introduction so consider any finite set
X which might for example be the domain
of our random Oracle then this finite
set X gives rise to a vector space e to
the X and how how do we construct this
vector space we just we just associate
with with each element of the finite set
a base vector in our vector space and
our superposition States or quantum
states are lying in the unity sphere in
this vector space this means we only
consider linear combinations of base
vectors such that Aquafresh coefficients
in the absolute and squared sum up to 1
okay as I said on the random Oracle
slide we usually use an argument like
yeah okay if the adversary had known H
of X star then it would have had to
query the random Oracle or next time
another question arises how this
translates to a sorry illustrate no
first we have to formalize how a random
Oracle would be accessible in the
quantum setting there's a question for
you oh yeah I can just read it out so is
there any restriction on the complexity
of preparing the coefficients alpha
I'm not sure if I understood the
question correctly so the coefficients
are just elements of the complex set see
maybe the person oh well I was just
asking if alpha I mean that's it's
usually exponential domain right you'll
be like exponentially many points is it
fair to count this one query if it's
really complex to prepare this
coefficient alpha X or do just say well
just be generous to that data
so in our abstractions we already
considered that we have a computer that
is somehow capable of preparing the
superposition so you're not charging
this so let's say alphas could be
solutions to like np-complete problems
we don't care it's just one query or
something or you know we just don't
bound the running time okay that's fine
okay circuits I'm just following up on
the begin expression so so this this
chronic query the superposition of X is
this is completely arbitrary right here
you place no restrictions for example it
doesn't have to be that there is a
polynomial time count circuit that
generates this state
I don't think we are assuming this okay
you
okay so now that we have some big
intuition on what a super position is I
have to tell you how random Oracle
queries on the super position could be
answered and to do so we have to give
some Unitarian transformation that is
associated with this random Oracle so we
have a random Oracle Oh which just Maps
elements of the domain X to the codomain
and through this Oracle we associate a
Unitarian transformation that takes as
input two registers the first register
corresponds to the domain of the
function and the second register
corresponds to the output of the
function and the first register will be
kept exactly as it is and in the second
register we exhort the Oracle value of
the input so this is just the definition
for the base States and we get a flu
mapping by extending this definition in
a linear fashion
other questions yet
okay okay and the last part the bug
modeling I want to show you is how we
modern adversaries that have quantum
access to this Oracle what we do is that
we view the adversary as stateful parts
that are interleaved with its Oracle
queries so we just slice it into the
parts that happen in between the quantum
Oracle queries which we will denote like
this
so this is ready adversary starts then a
quantum Oracle query happens and so on
and we can find that the earth random
Oracle query of the adversary in the
output register of AI
and what I just was trying to say on the
last slide is that we already have seen
in the random Oracle model tonight and
that we usually use this randomness
argument that correlates to being
capable of extracting the preimage from
the query and the question now would be
how can we generalize this argument to a
setting in which our queries and
superposition and the the first the
original helper result we had was one
way to hiding that was given by a rule
in 14 which is basically a quantum
generalization of random enter query and
what we have here is that we consider a
output behavior in two different
settings in both settings is interacting
with the random Oracle and it gets as
input some pre image in one case it gets
the Oracle value and the other case it
gets a uniform value and we want to
upper bound the change of behavior and
the upper bound is true Q where Q
denotes the number of Oracle queries
times the square root of a certain
probability and the probability is the
probability that we measure the random
query of a and it turns out that our
measurement results in the preimage so
what what we do in this game is that we
commit a random number
even before we study and when this
number of Oracle queries is achieved we
just bought the adversary we don't care
for its output we just measure the query
it just issued
okay as we already can see the bound is
non tight and to regard it has a linear
loss in the number of Oracle queries and
quadratic loss in extracting the
preimage and they have been recent
improvements for this tool we are using
the first that was in my classical one
retro hiding in 2018 where we could push
well where we saw that we could push the
queue under the square root at the cost
of additional restrictions and then
there was double-sided one way through
hiding in 2019 which got rid of the QR
together and in the next talk will see
that we can get rid of the quadratic
Clause but we will be reintroducing the
number of Oracle queries and those
additional restrictions make the one way
to hiding limits that are given a bit
more complicated to use I think I just
saw that nessa question
oh yeah okay no X star is a classical
state we are caring for because we will
see that X star is in our settings we
can think of X star as some message that
was encrypted and we want to invert the
ciphertext and get back to this message
and since we are assuming classical
schemes we still work with messages that
are classical and not in superposition
okay okay now I try to give you an
overview about what we already know if
you look into the literature there has
been a lot of work on the ever
transformation within the last year's
and there are some subtle and so not so
subtle differences in how if Oh actually
looks back in the respective paper and
some common ground of our recent modular
relations is that they can be dissected
into two steps so if we already can
assume our underlying scheme to be
deterministic we can just use the second
step of the arrow transformation that
was denoted by you originally in a
modular analysis of the Fujisaki Okamoto
transformation and it basically means
that we pick message uniformly at random
and we used this message to derive the
chemically but I'd show you some some
more details on this part in the next
slide and if we can't assume our
underlying scheme to be deterministic we
first have to rear analyze it and to do
so we use the T transform and what the T
transform basically does is that we do
not pick our encryptions at random
anymore but rather we just stick with
the randomness that is tied to the
message by another random Oracle okay so
this step looks the same in all of the
papers this step doesn't which is why I
now show you how the you transform might
differ from paper to paper
and question so pick a prime you assume
that it's a one-way right omits it
cannot possibly be semantically secure
so you assume that if it's one way and
then the you makes it CC is secure yeah
yes so I was trying to gloss over some
details here because the intermediate
scheme is required to have different
security notions with regards to which
reside we are actually looking at but I
give some details on this in a few
slides
so the strategy for others modular
proofs is to first durán demise by at
and achieve at some intermediate notion
I still have to specify and then to
apply you to achieve food security for
the camp and what all module
organizations also have in common is
that at least one of the steps has to
use one way to hiding so I'm not aware
of any results that could bypass using
one retro hiding or together
okay so details on the you transform
because there are a lot of variations
okay um what all variations have in
common is that encapsulation
follows the structure of picking a
random plaintext m and then using the
encryption scheme to encrypt the message
to the ciphertext C and then we derive
the key via some random Oracle applied
through this message and the ciphertext
in the caps relation works like this we
use the underlying the decryption
algorithm to get a plaintext candidate
and Prime unless it support then we just
return a rejection symbol and the key is
derived as in the encapsulation but with
respect to the plaintext candidate we
achieved wired the decryption algorithm
the first change we could make is to
derive the key only with respect to M
instead of seen
a second change we could make is that we
do not want to reject explicitly but
instead we will reject implicitly which
means that we in when decryption heads
we do not return the rejections but
instead we return ab pseudo-random value
that is derived from our message
candidate and I denote in this variant
by you to the non bot for the rest of
the truck and we already see that we
have four different cases for you by now
because they might change in the key
derivation process and in how they
reject then there's another change we
could make which I will call we encrypt
and so for encryption we do not only
reject if see if decryption fails but
also we will make a sanity check so we
will re encrypt the message that we
decrypt it to and check whether it
actually matches the other cipher text
we will carry it on
and I did note this version by using
this reputation symbol and the reason I
point this out is that the the original
you transform was given without this
rien krypton step and ever since they
have been tightness improvements and
tighten statements for transformation
you but they all come with we encryption
so in in the in the modular analysis we
didn't meet this rien Crips in step
because um our intermediate notion was
already strong enough to to cover this
head thing but the the work that has
been following to this paper to this
paper really needs this ring encryption
step and you want to take this into
account if you want to apply the you
transform to a deterministic scheme and
she was one of the follow-up papers
so you know so this new step the rien
Krypton check is important because the
decryption algorithm maybe mimic errors
is that why otherwise it's sort of
redundant right can you repeat the
question
yeah yeah of course so the
reintroduction step is is important
because the decryption algorithm might
make errors is that right yes I think
about it that way if you put drop three
encryption step rejections wouldn't work
the follow up reductions and I'm not
sure whether this only would affect
settings in which we have nonprofit
correctness okay I think stick would be
invalid right the ciphertext it would be
invalid
so friends valid sign for text there is
no guarantee correctness guarantee for
example but that already is taken care
of by see decrypting to bottom right
yeah but I'm saying conceivably
because you don't have control for the
one-wayness scheme I mean it's probably
not part of the one weighing definition
I see this is some bizarre behavior
okay okay the last variant I want to
show you is a variant that comes with
key confirmation and what we do now is
that we also to this earth with a PK e
ciphertext C we append a key
confirmation ciphertext e which will
basically work as a tag for the message
and during decapsulation we also check
whether this tech matches the oracle
value of m prime so this was a version
that we used in from Wadena modular
analysis where we actually wanted to
achieve a quantum proof and there it was
a technicality but it has been prevalent
ever since
maybe take this into a console I see
there's another question
mm so the question is besides we
encryption is there any other way to
decide whether ciphertext C is valid or
not
I'm not sure I understand the question
correctly so what you could also
consider would be to just use the tech
but we don't have any security
implications on that behalf if we just
drop the ring corruption step so I don't
know I do not know of any results and
yeah
maybe
maybe you need to restate the question
because I'm not sure what the question
is aiming at
I think perhaps so you can continue and
and you know the answer this question
later after the talk okay
okay now we've gathered all those
versions of the you transform
and what I can show you now is the
security statements that we know as of
today for this step because we'll see
soon after how we can apply the results
for the step or the open wall fo
transform
you
so in 2018 there was a first really cool
result because it achieved Heights a
serious security but it came at the
price of requiring perfect correctness
and to translate ability and this
transform eligibility means that you can
simulate ciphertext such that they are
computationally indistinguishable from
real cipher texts but the two sets don't
really intersect and the intuition
behind this proof was that by using the
intermediate notion of the strengths
relatability you can circumvent one way
to hiding or together which is cool
because we don't lose a factor of Q or a
square root but the proof required
perfect correctness to to keep our
reductions simulation of the decryption
or occur consistent and we try to look
into how we could generalize this result
for nonprofit correctness and it's
really not straightforward because yeah
for deterministic schemes it's really
hard to give a a correctness definition
that makes sense for such schemes but
still which is what we are trying to
achieve for our security proofs
and there was another result in 2019
that stated if our PK is Kim is FFC and
better injective we can achieve CCA
security with either quadratics loss in
the advantage or this is the result that
will be presented in the next talk
nearly understand the number of random
Oracle queries which is pretty cool
because it gets rid of the square root
for the first time and FFC means that is
how to find a valid ciphertext that is
an encryption of a message such that the
cipher text does not decrypt to the
message so
yeah it's it's some kind of correctness
requirement and Etta injectivity means
the following so now we are only
considering schemes that are a
deterministic so we can view the
encryption algorithm once the key pair
is fixed as a function from the message
space to the ciphertext space and yet
injectivity means that this function is
injective with probability 1 minus h
aware the probability is taken over the
key generation
so what all three results share is that
they have to need the rhythm that they
need to use the we encryption variant
and what was also proven in 2019 is that
there is an equivalency for implicit
reject so if we reject implicitly it
doesn't really matter whether we derive
the key via H of M C or H of M
if one of the transforms is CCA security
others as well and then there's an
implication result for explicit reject
that states if one of those versions
which means both of those versions are
CCA secure we can also use an explicit
reject variant where we derive the key
via H of M if we add key confirmation
okay now I want to show you exactly
which theorems you would have to apply
to achieve the respective security
statements because yeah they have been a
lot of papers and maybe it's handy to to
have a slide in which everything is
gathered together and compared so in the
first setting we consider intermediate
schemes that are just translatable
deterministic and perfectly correct and
we achieve tight security for versions
with implicit reject by sightings I
chose are in 2018 and we can also extend
this result to versions with explicit
reject once we use key confirmation and
this result was given by young Israel in
2019 then we could scale down the the
security requirements a bit to being
just one way in 2019 with the additional
requirements of FFC correctness and
better injectivity but what we already
see is that the upper bound is less
tight than before because we either get
the square root or we lose a linear
effect of the number of random Oracle
queries and this will be presented in
the next talk
and on a high level we see that we have
a trade-off between generality of the
result and tightness as I already
implied on the last slide we have two
more theorems that those are the the
equivalency and implication result that
were given in 2019 and if we tie them
together with the results we had above
we also achieve tight security for
implicit reject if we derive the key via
h of MC
and we also achieved the bounds that
were given above if we
derive the key either way and if we
explain reject explicitly and add key
confirmation
you
okay and now I want to tie stuff
together so we've already seen here's a
vast array of different variants of the
you transformation
and yeah as I said I now show you how to
put stuff together
like the new barians have all comes in
many flavors by now and the recent
tightness improvements for the you
transform we've seen in the last part
imply tightness improvements per fo
whenever the proof was given in a
modular manner and even if a proof is
non-modular we have a nice with the
result that we can now derive from any
security statement for implicit reject a
security statement for the other version
and since there also have been
non-modular proofs III now try to give a
comparison of what knowledge we've
already gathered for our CCA bonds
okay so first the the first results a
very general in the setting in the
regard that we only have to assume
one-way security and all those
constructions come with the same
security bound and the the bounds were
proven by young as I'll in 2018 and 2019
mmm but they are not right in in two
regards so here we have the linear laws
on the number of Oracle queries here we
have the square root and what young at I
already noted in 2019 was that if we
assume CPA security instead of one-way
security we can basically push thank you
another square root
then there was work by my co-authors and
me that extended the setting of CPA
security to a version that comes with
implicit reject and what we did was
basically that we improved the bound in
in the correctness term so what you can
see is that we now have the bound as
before but squared what we had to do is
to additionally require the strands
relatability required that this means we
have to destroy any simulate cipher
texts or we could try to achieve
destroying simulate ability generically
by puncturing and by puncturing I mean
that we remove one message from the
message space and this message will be
taken to generate cipher texts that are
now fake cipher texts
and given that we have this equivalence
and implication results we can also
generalize this result to the other
cases we have been discussing
last year there has been another
security result for a fall that also
starts from CPA security but doesn't
have to assume disjoint relatability and
it doesn't have to puncture the message
space
it comes with exactly the same bound you
know if we simplify and let out if we
ignore our constant factors and it has
an additional requirement which is
called attend activities so record that
for the you transform we had to assume
at injectivity for some results and this
is just sucking air plugging tea and
aunt you together so now we have to
assume at a conductivity of the tea
transformed and in the next talk we'll
see how to improve this upper bound
quite a lot because now we get rid of
the square root
and again we can extend the analysis to
other variants of the fo transformation
okay the last thing I wanted to cover is
whether one weight were hiding
automatically has to imply quadratic
laws so in 2018 Leo and jamjam stated
ten questions to the NIST community and
one of those questions was whether the
square root in the advantage is actually
meaningful in the sense that we can
match it by some attack or whether it's
just a mirror proof artifact
and last year last year last year we
were trying to say however that by
stating that the square root might be
impossible to avoid and we pointed to a
recently published impossibility result
and yeah well now you've already been
spoilered because some of the results
get past the square root and apparently
it's not impossible to avoid and now the
quests might be okay how do we place
this impossibility result as it isn't
there some kind of contradiction and to
give you some some quick intuition why
this result is the correct but but we
can still bypass the square root I
recall that we model our attackers with
quantum access to the Oracle as a
sequence of the Unitarian transforms and
the I through and America query can be
found in the output register of AI and
what all one way to hiding applications
until now had in common was a strategy
in which we just expected the the
preimage in question from Oracle queries
so we in a sense we only considered the
input-output behavior of a and what yang
is in nineteen stated was that this
query extraction approach has to lead to
quadratic north so what you could
already see is that if you want to give
a reduction that is tighter that gets
rid of the square root you your
reduction will have to follow a more
sophisticated approach
and what Ron will show you in the next
talk is that you could not stick to
considering input-output behavior but
rather consider is internal workings and
the intuition behind this result is that
to distinguish between the Oracle value
and the random value to which the Oracle
is reprogrammed I would have to measure
and it would have to measure in a base
width with respect to the preimage X
star so in a sense the measurement
already reveals the preimage and to be
be capable of measuring with respect to
the external it the extent would have to
be encoded in in the code of a and this
lets us extract big star in a another
way but yeah this intuition was very
well intuitive and the next talk will
give a way more detailed and formal
treatment of this setting ok thank you
for listening and I'm happy to answer
any questions thanks Catherine
if there are any quick questions we can
take them but otherwise yeah sorry about
ten minutes so I guess I have a question
which is I guess about the next talk but
I'll ask you anyway you know because
this intuition was was pretty easy clear
one slight intuition there is no analog
of this in the classical world right I
mean this is sort of using the adversary
as a not like as if the court of the
adversary in the information theoretic
kind of random Oracle like world there
is no advantage to be had in the
classical world is that right so you
were asking whether okay so so you were
asking why do we even have to
to consider non black box approach
basically right in the I'm asking really
that in the classical world considering
non blank an adversary is a non black
box doesn't give you any advantage in
the information theoretic setting right
but here it does seem to give you so
it's little and you're saying it you
know in some sense sir is there a way to
sort of formalize this intuition that if
you don't look inside the adversary the
only you you really need the quadratic
loss while it was formalized in the work
by young as mmm-hmm this this paper has
covered this a shrink okay interesting
thanks maybe have like just a very quick
question so you're talking this kind of
to almost well seemingly disjoint
components obviously they connect one is
this beautiful set of results just about
one-wayness to this extraction results
how you pull them one witnessed abiding
or kindness but but but basically this
result about measuring random Quarian
and the restrictions and zones the
second part was about this CCA
deductions use it through the tolls of
CC papers they pretty much I'm just
trying to see how they come at did they
you know modifies the details of then
use one of the other results all they
had to work hard so essentially all
those all the CC papers connect to one
of the results in the first cup of the
talks and use it white box
so in some sense how quantum are those
papers that you put on this slide or are
those papers essentially classical but
just reduce it to one of those quantum
papers which don't kill about BCC
security okay so if we go back to the
slide you so you were asking are all of
those results just possess of applying
the quantum reside for the you transform
to a classical result for the T
transform right sorry the question
doesn't just say so since the first part
of the doc you look at this you know no
CeCe
encryption just very clean thing quantum
random Oracle extraction you know like
this when winners to extraction is where
like a one set of results that you
stayed under restrictions and then the
second part was more about CC security
so I'm trying to see also subtleties
about this you variant and so on of all
these papers basically think oh if you
do this kind of thing we reduced it to
quantum paper number one if you do this
we reduce quantum paper to so also three
all those results classical's it just
reduced to a different quantum think how
modulate is oh they they have to like to
control stop periodically
No all of the papers use different
techniques so what when I try to do is
to give a most uniform comparison of the
results this is why it might look like
all of the papers just use the result
for the you transform but they all
differ a bit in the intermediate notion
and yeah there are many subtleties and
it's really a bit complicated to give a
uniform description so essentially you
have to know both script and quantum to
do to do this papers it's not like they
just read use it to a known quantum
paper about this extraction so it's
perfect but but if beginning just if I
may you know it's quite conceivable that
there is underlying so if quantum query
lower bound
you know the grain that's that's what
you're getting at right yeah I guess
yeah I'm just trying to see how modular
yeah I would love if it was actually it
wasn't the prettiest and I would love if
everything was less signal and
essentially said you know you can
basically use working with quantum
random Oracle to a couple of really
beautiful papers and then we can think
classically from their own so that's
that would be my hope but yeah that
would be nice
so so let's take the rest of questions
applying for Katherine and uh we'll
reconvene in two minutes for Ron
Steinfeld's talk maybe actually let's
give it a little bit more time we'll
reconvene at a 10:20 Pacific time so
that's in seven minutes